hello again scp fans we've once again
sparked up the anomatron 6000 our
state-of-the-art supercomputer that
takes countless data streams from the
scp foundation's various anomalies and
allows us to simulate potential
scenarios that could never normally
occur for example what if boba fett one
of fiction's most iconic galactic bounty
hunters took out the sarkic menace that
is the flesh that hates well let's press
the button and find out a long time ago
in a barely explored corner of a galaxy
far far away the rhythmic blink of
bright red emergency lights brought the
hunter back to consciousness beneath the
tinted visor of his helmet his vision
was still blurry from the blow he had
taken to the head as his ship had jolted
to a stop blinking away the haze
clouding his eyesight he focused on the
light still flashing up at him from the
console in front of the seat he was
strapped into wait was he he lifted a
gloved hand to double check still secure
buckled in tight finally able to see
again the bounty hunter turned to the
console checking the readouts on the
circular screens of his ship's cockpit
it didn't take running a quick
diagnostic for him to realize his
predicament as durable and heavily
armored as his trusty fire spray was the
vessel had taken a pretty nasty hit he
knew he was taking a risk flying through
an area of space controlled by the
infamous crimson dawn the crime
syndicate maintained a fragile alliance
with the hunter's slothful slug-like
employer but after spotting his ship
trying to pass through their territory
undetected they had retaliated sending a
squad of ships after the fire spray and
outmaneuvering them hadn't been easy
especially the smaller single person
fighters that could zip around at much
faster speeds than the hunter's heavy
gunship but the syndicate had used its
fighters as merely a distraction drawing
his attention away from the larger
attack ship drawing in from the rear
receiving a full blast from an ion
cannon was bad enough the energy bolt
had struck the hunter's ship serving a
direct hit that slowed his vessel down
to a crawl albeit still intact for now
ion blasts weren't designed to cause
lasting damage to a ship only to disrupt
all electronic systems on board from his
cockpit the bounty hunter knew exactly
why his adversaries had done this they
wanted to capture him alive and possibly
take his fire spray too he wasn't about
to let that happen the ship had been
passed down to him by his father along
with the armor he now wore that made him
instantly recognizable as one of the
most feared hunters in the galaxy but
having his ship rendered without
navigation systems or control over the
engines meant he couldn't steer it clear
of the path of an oncoming fighter the
smaller ship moved to swerve out of the
way only too late it clipped the fire
spray's wing causing the hunter to lurch
forward and hit his head as his ship
spun out of control drifting away lost
in space by the time he came back around
he found himself adrift in an unfamiliar
uncharted corner of the galaxy his ship
was still badly damaged running on a
reserve of emergency power that was
quickly depleting the hunter fumbled
with the controls taking a look at the
star map on his display he didn't
recognize this quadrant or even the
system he was in there was one planet
looming ahead a green and blue world
with a single neighboring moon it was
then the hunt to recognize what the red
light had been warning him about in its
damaged state the fire spray had been
caught in the planet's gravitational
pull and was now hurtling towards the
surface holding on tight bracing himself
for impact boba fett prepared for a
particularly bumpy lamping the entire
ship buckled as it passed through the
planet's upper atmosphere the metal were
creaking as scraps were torn away from
the outer hull by extreme g-forces boba
yanked at the steering columns barely
able to change the course of his ship's
descent the power was still minimal
after the ion attack practically running
on fumes looking out of the large front
viewport vet could see streaks of heat
as his fire spray plummeted to the
surface he had an idea a risky move but
it just might work if it didn't then his
storied career as the galaxy's most
infamous bounty hunter might just come
to an unremarkable anti-climactic ending
pulling out the controls he repositioned
the ship's remaining fin-like wing the
one still mostly operational and angled
the fire spray so that its rear boosters
were facing towards the planet its
internal gyro system keeping him sat
upright still tumbling straight down now
in landing position all boba could do
was hold tight and pray prayers that
were answered when the console lit up
with an alert the heat of the re-entry
had jump-started the engines reigniting
the gunship's propulsion system not
enough for sustained flight but adequate
to allow the hunter to control his
descent and lessen the impact of the
rough landing the fire spray came to a
crashing halt in the snow still mostly
intact but too badly damaged to take off
clambering his way out boba fett
examined the wreckage of his ship it had
been in far worse scraps over the years
but every time the fire spray sustained
damage he couldn't help but think of
what his father jango would say or his
donor as some would call him given that
bobo was a pure unaltered genetic clone
of his dad turning around he looked out
over the expanse of the frozen region
he'd crashed on the wind carried with it
an icy bite that was only shielded from
it by the insulated flight suit he wore
under his green painted plates of
biscar's steel armor he lowered the
antenna on his mandalorian helmet using
its viewfinder to survey the horizon
instantly his eyes spotted a sign a worn
sheet of metal half buried in the snow
there was something off about this sign
though that instantly told boba he
wasn't on hoth ulum orto plutonia or any
other ice planet he knew of he trudged
closer to the sign crossing the frozen
tundra alone the cape over his shoulder
whipping in the freezing cold gale where
there was a sign there could easily be
civilization maybe even somewhere fett
could get parts to fix his inherited
ship he forced himself not to stop and
examine the sign but couldn't help
glancing at it as he passed boba
couldn't recognize the lettering written
on it at all not the characters that had
printed on the middle nor the word
painted over it in red at first he
thought it might be aubresh but the
closer he got he realized it was a
language he didn't understand continuing
on past it boba tried to put thoughts of
the sign out of his head unaware that it
read lake baikal siberia and that
someone had painted the russian word for
run over it it didn't take long for boba
to reach the civilization that he was
looking for or what was left of it
anyway the small fishing town reminded
him a little of the city of moss espa
back on tatooine although it looked to
have been abandoned for quite some time
the rickety buildings were all
constructed out of wooden planks with a
thick coating of frost over almost every
surface as boba marched further in a
gunslinger walking into a frozen ghost
town there was almost total silence the
cold winds had died down to barely a
whisper now the stranded bounty hunter
looked around finding no signs of
anything nearby no spaceport no jawas he
could trade with no townsfolk to ask for
directions no signs of life
something moved behind him causing boba
to instinctively whip around to face it
producing his ee3 carbine blaster with a
draw speed rivaled by a few of the
fastest hands in the galaxy his weapon
was trained on
nothing whatever had caused the sound
was nowhere to be seen keeping his gun
up and at the ready in one hand boba
reached for a button on one of his
gauntlets within his helmet the pure
white of the snow blinked away replaced
by a blue filter providing him with a
heads up display that highlighted any
nearby heat signatures there was a trail
on the ground just a few feet from him
not tracks my view just a single streak
of warmth left carved through the snow
cautiously boba followed it the trail
curved around a nearby shack and then
disappeared through a hole that had been
punched through one of its walls the
wooden planks it was built from were all
splintered outwards as if something
large had burst out of it inside the
shack had been coated in enough frost to
freeze everything solid cups and plates
at the dinner table looked like they'd
been encased in carbonite looking around
the dark abandoned interior boba barely
noticed something slithering down
towards him from the ceiling a windy
fleshy appendage whipped around boba's
arm locking it tightly in place he
pulled against it with all his strength
but the bounty hunter couldn't free his
hand or the blaster he was holding
turning to see his attacker through the
boards of the upper floor fett could
make out a writhing massive shadow
attached to the long grotesque appendage
that now had him in an arm lock in all
his years of bounty hunting he'd never
seen a species like it whatever it was
his baskar and flight suit were
protecting it from feeling its
disgusting slimy grip against his skin
although he wasn't too keen on being
held by this monster for much longer
with his free hand boba tried to wrench
the tentacle off of him only to feel it
snaking further and tighter around his
arm bending it in the opposite direction
his elbow was meant to bend boba grunted
stifling a scream under his helmet as he
felt his arm on the verge of snapping
but the pain brought back reminders of
his lessons his training under his
various mentors his father aura even old
bane even with his blaster arm ensnared
a good bounty hunter was never unarmed
knocking the gauntlet on his free arm
against his leg to activate it he lifted
his fist upwards as a streak of flame
erupted from the mandalorian vamp race
setting fire to the wooden floor above
and the creature which shrieked in pain
as it caught a light relinquishing its
grip thinking fast and moving at a speed
to match boba leaked out of the way as
the huge monster came crashing through
the burning wood planks had he not
rolled to a safe distance just in time
then it would have landed on him
crushing the bounty hunter under its
weight back on his feet boba spun on his
heel and opened fire with his now freed
blaster each blast of the red laser
light illuminating the horrific sight of
what had attacked him it was a mass of
flesh distorted and disfigured like a
bloated coagulated wound given form it
might once have been a person but now
extra legs that sprouted beneath it arms
having melted into slimy blood red
tentacles that were flailing in pain as
the creature tried to douse the fire
boba backed out of the shack's front
entrance still firing his carbine
blaster its bolts were having little
effect on the fleshy inhuman monster
seeming to only cause it irritation
rather than leaving lasting damage but
as the infamous hunter moved his foot
behind him a wooden porch step snapped
beneath causing him to topple over
landing on his back in the snow his
blaster had fallen from his hands as he
came crashing down forcing him to roll
over and reach for it that's when he saw
the others emerging from the abandoned
rural town a group of nightmarish
abominations were slithering out of
nearby shacks they shambled towards boba
each one of them looking different from
the next but no less stomach churning in
their fleshy blood-soaked appearances
some were bipedal walking on the
remnants of two legs but with their
entire upper body fused into a single
monstrous mass others look like they had
once been small animals but had been
cruelly and unnaturally twisted into
amorphous slimy mutations of their
former selves the horde of beings a
veritable smorgasbord of flesh that
hates were crawling towards boba he had
spent the earliest parts of his
childhood surrounded by cloners on
kamino alien experts in genetics since
then he'd been all over the galaxy and
met people of all different species it
wasn't hard for boba to see what these
things these monsters were they were the
townsfolk that once lived in this
snow-covered place or at least they used
to be people now they were horrific from
behind him the first creature the one
that had drawn him out reemerged still
enraged but as he turned to look at it
making sure he was aware of all threats
surrounding him boba spotted its skin
the part where he had singed with his
flamethrower were still severely burned
practically reduced to a cinder fire
that could hurt them reaching into the
ground to retrieve and stow his blaster
boba felt something tugging at the
weapon pulling it in the opposite
direction another of the fleshy monsters
a crawling spider-like collection of
arms and legs with no body or head had
flung an appendage outwards and grabbed
the carbine trying to pull it back boba
slipped in the snow and was being
dragged towards the writhing monstrosity
a loud bang echoed around the nearby
town punctuated by a bright red light
soaring through the sky and gently
floating back down towards the ground
the white hot flare filled the area with
a glow the creatures all momentarily
turning their attention to it sensing
its heat that split second was his one
chance all of boba's instincts every
lesson jango had taught him told him to
strike first if he wanted to make a way
alive he dropped the blaster leaving it
in the creature's grip he had spares
back on the fire spray but they'd be no
good to him if he was dead hitting one
of the tiny switches on his vambrace two
scorching hot flames spat from the
exhaust of boba's jetpack immediately he
was lifted up off the ground hovering
just above the roofs of the small wooden
structures around him in that same micro
the abominations of flesh turned their
collective attention back to their
airborne prey the ones that still had
heads or had grown extra disfigured and
misshapen growths in the place of a head
looked up at boba to them he was merely
another vessel for them to infect with
the same disease that plagued them but
little did any of them know he was the
boba fett the galaxy's deadliest most
famous baskar-clad bounty hunter and a
good bounty hunter was never unarmed
igniting in an instant the flickering
nozzle end of boba's wrist-mounted
flamethrower began spraying super-heated
fuel over the horde of monstrosities
below long tongues of orange flame
engulfed the writhing slithering
creatures burning them to a crisp as
boba fett rained unrelenting hell down
on the flesh that hates hovering above
them he had given himself enough high
ground to gain an advantage ironically
the distance boba had put between
himself and the monsters wasn't
dissimilar to the detachment he had for
those he had killed or captured for
jabba the hutt in the past they had all
been people too just like these twisted
masses of flesh had once been human
putting those thoughts down like he'd
been taught to boba's attention was
focused on blasting any of the fleeing
creatures burning them with enough
intensity to leave little behind but
charred remains except he had forgotten
in his haste to check behind him the
monster that had first attacked him was
making quick work of scaling the nearest
single-story shack and flailed one of
its appendages at boba it caught him in
mid-air plucking him out of the sky and
wrenching him back down to the snowy
ground once more winded boba was
grasping to catch his breath underneath
his helmet he certainly didn't need to
look to know his jet pack had most
likely been damaged by his fall but that
was currently the least of his worries
towering above looming over him the
repulsive monster looked like it was
rearing up to pounce boba reached to
relight his flamethrower only for his
gauntlet to spark it had taken a hit on
the way down too
desperation set in he lifted his knee
and fired two darts from the micro
cannons mounted on his yellow knee pads
the spiked darts became embedded in the
fleshy creature's mass barely phasing it
loading a wrist rocket boba raised his
other vambrace to fire only for the arm
he wore on it to be grabbed by one of
the other creatures still burning half
alive meanwhile the one on the roof
looked ready to leap it sprung into the
air ready to come crashing down to kill
the feared former bounty hunter a bright
light burst from somewhere nearby it
wasn't another flare this one was a
blinding eruption of pure white even
through the tinted t-shaped visor of his
helmet it stung boba's eyes so much that
he had to cover his face with his hand
as he peered back he almost mistook the
light gray of the sky for the same light
looking around the monster had vanished
those that were left still writhing
their amorphous bodies coated with fire
which rapidly spread to the wood of the
nearby houses keeping his guard up as he
always did bubba climbed to his feet
lifting the gauntlet with a miniature
blaster mounted on it to defend himself
he'd seen and even used disintegration
weapons in the past but the bounty
hunter had never known anything to make
a creature like that monster completely
vanish in a single flash he turned at a
sound not one of the creatures or the
gentle crackling of flames but the
gentle crunch of snow under someone's
foot three strangers walked slowly up to
bova not one among them flinching when
he lifted his vambrace standing his
ground their clothing was patchwork
cobbled together from scraps but looked
similar to the same cloaks worn by the
jedi of old as the group approached him
the bounty hunter noticed their bodies
had also been altered although not in
the same way as the vile fleshy
creatures that now littered the snow
around him metal work mechanized
components and devices of all manner
protruded from their uncovered arms and
necks pieces of machinery embedded in
their skulls in place of their eyes boba
was no stranger to cyborgs those who had
modified their own bodies with
technological augmentations and
modifications one of the three was
missing an entire hand in its place with
what looked like some kind of cannon
still warm from having just fired the
cloaked mechanized trio looked at fett
with curiosity as if they were examining
no admiring his armor just like his
damaged ship boba's armor belonged to
his father and if these three wanted to
take it they'd have to kill him for it i
take it that was your flare that
distracted them he growled beneath his
helmet the front most of the group
nodded bowing his head gently indicating
he meant no harm indeed we saw something
a vessel we believe fall from the sky
not far from here the part man part
machine replied was that your craft
warrior lowering his arm at last boba
nodded in response don't suppose you
know where i can get my ship fixed the
hunter asked we may be able to assist
you one of the two interjected you have
machinery we watched you use it to fight
are you one of us i give my allegiance
to no one boba stated as he eyed the
speaker he barely looked older than a
teenager who are you people some have
called us mechanites others know us as
the church of the broken god the leader
spoke up in reply little of that matters
now not since the flesh of around this
place they spread via skin contact only
the parts of our bodies we have yet to
mechanize are still vulnerable to their
infection i certainly hope nothing
touched you
boba took a look over his shoulder at
the bodies of the still-burning
creatures glad that his helmet was
pressurized and his flight suit was on
tight the flesh he muttered to himself
i'm fine he declared with certainty in
that case the lead mechanite said let's
see about fixing your ship shall we now
go and check out
scp-096 versus scp-343
and scp-049 vs scp-173
if you want to hear more about the
outcomes of more chaotic clashes between
anomalies battling each other for
supremacy